hey everyone is Jojo and today I am so
excited I'm about to be giving
unsuspected BuzzFeed are surprised to
see when a ders makeovers let's do this
[Music]
everyone's just staring at me and I just
feel the energy in the room and I just
don't know what to expect I'm not
nervous I like trying new looks I'm
really nervous I need to change it up a
bit
I need like a fresh style Oh Mike yeah
it's a Joe dress you a fan you know what
I see here is like like the Terminator
[Laughter]
yes
Jojo right I love her so much she's
really cool and yeah well you're about
to get thrown my style oh my god
ponytail Jojo makeover first things
first
oh you have it rock solid head or yard
is your head sensitive it's not
sensitive at all okay be inside like
that you might change that today but I'd
like to think I'm a colorful person but
compared to you like listen I've always
wanted to buy one of these bows but I'm
like that's I feel like I'm 25 years old
and like should I be wearing a bow
yes yeah 50 you really ten years part
you know okay honestly I think whatever
you think will look best with the with
the look I think I'm thinking one of the
big ones okay yeah God you smile a let's
we're gonna I'm gonna use the hands
first okay
get up in there you might have a bit of
a bullet because your hair in the back
might flip up hang out down there I'll
put that on my resume Jojo gave me a
mole at one time yes if I am hurting you
I'm just tell me oh listen girl I'm
Latino my abuela did this growing up
yeah right
yeah it doesn't hurt anymore how amazing
this feels nice you were gonna oh wait a
second you know what I feel the best a
back scratch on the hairbrush you've
never done that you are getting omega
I'm gonna turn into a team Internet
Queen okay
we're almost a ponytail time are you
gonna put on a performance why must now
so you you work out much yes I do what's
the best part was the worst part
well the best part is like you get to
work with all your friends worst part is
that you have a method kill you better
know it's like an experience it's very
pull it tight girl one two three here we
go oh yeah this is what I grew up with
ice please oh mama she's been getting
it's like yes she got you're fine you're
fine you don't feel like it it's good it
doesn't Paul what are you talking about
it poles oh oh she tied it's not painful
yes I can tell it's tight
it's actually not painful because I can
handle pain oh I think you were like an
umbrella in your past life I don't know
what's happening oh I'm great how are
you I'm okay you're gonna have like this
old clip you do situation in the back
because you're fixing a bullet if you
won't think I go through so much
hairspray probably like one every four
months
like not actually bad and you do this
every day
every single day no joke I just want to
say I respect you so much because you
are like an entrepreneur thank you we're
like doing it that honestly means a lot
thank you show me where showing you well
I love
I do so much but I just really care
about it are you ready
hey are you ready for this are you
hanging on the Aegean Sea yeah I'm on
the edge of my seat
alright we got one more whisper spot
okay yeah ah I feel like I'm being
crowned I don't know why I'm holding my
breath
booyah oh my I look 10 years younger
instant yes instant this is adorable
oh my gosh
Jojo I didn't know my head was shaped
like this all the time
wait like it's wick yeah you're doing a
great job
yeah I try I try to feel like a Barbie
doll /cu inator and I'm here for it you
look like a Barbie doll put the Java
hold the we're going to drop my I'm
holding in here this is the drum and
this yeah there you go
pajama hold the drama what are we gonna
keep this yeah yeah I think I'm gonna be
walking like this all day but definitely
fun yeah I'm gonna be surprised
[Music]
[Applause]